so the uh mike lindell the mike lindell
no the the fbi read on mike lindell
we've got more information apparently
they're targeting him over damage to a
protected computer and identity theft
sounds a lot like bs but of course
things have been getting pretty crazy
with the fbi at the at the washington
bureau they've been going after trump
now it's just getting worse 40 subpoenas
into trump allies and then get the mike
lindell thing and so we're going to talk
about that and get into great detail
about what's happening at the highest
levels of politics in this country and
we have another funny story that we
talked about the other day having to do
with trump and a secret meeting
and who was at that secret meeting on
the golf course with no golf clubs and
we can now formally debunk all of the
insane lies that they pushed about this
story so that's going to be fun and then
the big news
is that
the railway uh the rail workers
are set to strike on friday unless a
deal gets approved at last minute but
one of the unions a couple of i think
maybe the biggest one of the biggest has
rejected the deal that biden tried
brokering if this strike happens it is
going to impact every level i mean
long-term trains for transport amtrak is
getting
they're shutting those down
we're going to see 2 billion in economic
damage per day and uh this means your
goods
stuff you might find at the store won't
be there or at least it'll be delayed
like you know nothing will happen for a
few weeks but then eventually you'll
stop seeing the things you like and the
prices are gonna start going up so this
is big and it is an apocalyptic scenario
for democrats right before the midterms
because
even if it's not joe biden's fault and
he's trying he's the democrats are
trying to do a lot to stop this strike
from happening
voters are just going to say the economy
is bad i'm going to vote for the other
guy so we're going to get in we will get
into all of that but before we do my
friends head over to stronger bones and
life dot com i'm sorry no i eat right
and feel feel well how do we have the
wrong thing
right eat right and feelwell.com i read
the wrong url it's keto elevate c8 mct
oil powder it's from biotrust we also do
shout out biotrust's um
collagen as well but this is a
medium chain triglyceride power you can
add to your drinks i like putting in my
coffee it's actually really good and my
friends since i started the
i started with keto
and now i'm in like a modified low carb
kind of thing clearly i'm drinking
coconut water so there's some sugar back
in my diet but i dropped 30 pounds no
joke legit 30 pounds and it's uh with
the help of biotrust no joke literally
so head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you will get
a 60 day money back guarantee keto
elevate provides your body only c8 the
most ketogenic mct that means it
provides support for energy levels
healthy appetite management mental
clarity and focus athletic performance
you know and just per like i always talk
to your doctor about this stuff but i'll
tell you my personal experience when i
cut out the sugars i definitely felt
like i had more energy i felt like more
mental clarity i i think it really did
did work tremendously
keto elevate personally it's my favorite
mct powder on the market today and this
is true because uh someone brought some
over that was different and we tried it
not a fan you'll get free shipping on
every order and for every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids police help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you will also get free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order
i cut out the bread and the sugar and
i've i've never felt better so check out
eatrightandfeelwell.com
shout out to biotrust and also don't
forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
directly and as a member not only are
you supporting our team of journalists
who write the news and fact check it
every day and of course we are news
guard certified that's right you'll also
get access to our uncensored after show
at 11 p.m those go up monday through
thursday and we're going to have a
really good time tonight with a lot to
talk about because joining us today we
have a couple really awesome guests we
have also real quick smash the like
button subscribe the channel share the
show with your friends and joining us
today devin nunes great to be with you
tim who are you devin nunes i am a
confidential human informant for the fbi
and also moonlight is ceo true social oh
is that first one true
we never know
okay i'll i'm gonna assume it's true i
heard there's lots of conspiracy
theories going on right now so i might
as well start a new i heard you can
teleport that's that's one thing yeah
yeah we'll talk about that later but
yeah yeah he can that's right i mean
the only way the only way you you can't
teleport the only way that would be true
is if the news was wrong
but and they're never wrong so clearly
you can teleport uh we also have
returning to the show derek harvey good
to be here and who
are you sir
uh derek harvey retired colonel a
candidate for
washington county commissioner and i
used to work for devin nunes as his lead
investigator
and he can also teleport yes yeah
absolutely yeah there's because there's
multiple stories about you guys
teleporting yeah i'm impressed you guys
got to tell me how to do that yeah we
also have we even got pictures on our
phones of us being in two places
well
either that or the media is wrong
we also got luke caskey
fbi informant you said
i'll get away from you there a little
bit my name is lukerdowski of we are
change.org good to be back today i'm
wearing a new representation of uncle
sam but instead of uncle sam it is an
irs agent saying we want your cut of our
we want our cut of your 601 venmo
transaction if you like the shirt you
can get it on thebestpoliticoshorts.com
because you do i'm here thank you so
much for having me that shirt is awesome
i was telling luke that i kind of need
one of those later on so i'm excited to
get into the news today thrilled to have
devin and daryl let's get going so the
first story we have is an update on
what's happening with mike lindell this
story was crazy it broke last night you
know we're sitting here trying to do
this show i'm trying to talk about ariel
because the new movie she she's black
and there's a big controversy and then
all of a sudden luke is like breaking
news we got to check it out mike lindell
had his phone seized by the fbi so we
have some updates
post millennial reports the search
warrant shows mike lindell phone seized
in identity theft damage of protected
computer investigation the search
warrant for the phone seizure reveals
that it was taken over an identity
identity theft and damage okay they're
just repeating themselves they say we
know this documents posted by lindell
reveal the reported reasoning with a
page titled items to be seized reading
that the physical cellular telephone
assigned number redacted
lindell cell phone and all records and
information on the lindell cell phone
that constitutes fruits evidence or
instrument instrumentalities of identity
theft as well as intentional damage to a
protected computer and or a conspiracy
to commit identity theft and or to cause
intentional damage to a protected
computer
that's just crazy i was talking to a guy
earlier today
regular guy you know just a regular guy
and he said how are they getting away
with this
how did they go after what 40 subpoenas
targeting trump allies
and i just want to add to that
you'd think i mean we're going on what
year seven of hoaxes targeting trump and
his allies
how does this keep happening why hasn't
it stopped it seems to be getting worse
but um we're lucky enough to have uh you
know you uh devin and derek seem
seemingly the experts on this on what's
going on so
you tell me man how do they keep doing
this how is it how are they getting away
with it you know what's interesting
about lindell especially is that he's a
brilliant guy i don't know if he's ever
been on your show before but he's
absolutely brilliant he's a brilliant
marketer
and passionate guy
and he's the frickin my pillow guy
i mean he's just he's funny everybody
knows who he is because he's been on tv
for so long but i will tell you that
this is this actually really happened so
i don't want people thinking that i'm
really i'm a fbi informant
but
i was talking to him
just in the last i don't know about
about a week ago and i was i was
laughing so i was actually just trying
to get some pointers on true social
because we're
we're beginning advertising
and i asked him
you know you know because he always
wants to talk about election issues
which is which is fine and he's very
passionate about it
and we were talking about the january 6
commission and you know how you know i
had said look what i've said from the
very beginning of that is is that you
know writing's not okay breaking in the
capital is not okay but where's the 14
000 hours of videotape
and he tells me
you know that i've never gotten this is
what mike liddell told me just just a
week ago
and i'm paraphrasing but i've never
been contacted by anyone
for any of this you know for all the
stuff that he's that he said out there
so
and then
just he shouldn't have went to that
hardy site right right hearties
well tim trying to answer your question
here the first thing i thought about was
in 2017 on msnbc chuck schumer went on
national television and said that the
intelligence agencies have quote six
waves from sunday to get back at you and
he was hinting at the intelligence
agencies doing a revenge plot against
donald trump do you think there's some
merit to this especially from your
information from the inside that there
that this is the intelligence agencies
heading back against trump with the
battles that were happening within the
white house well they were already
weaponized before that so when schumer
says that remember so he probably
already knows because it was
the democratic party clinton campaign
that paid for this whole operation
that probably started in 2015 so schumer
probably already knows when he makes
that very
infamous statement that you know of
course is seen by
30 40 percent of the country but the
rest of the country doesn't know it
exists
also i would just
what are the things that the fbi has
chosen not to do i mean they're looking
at identity theft and putting resources
into that when they didn't touch the
hunter biden
laptop
they didn't look at the thousands of
assaults on federal officers in portland
and other places during 2020
the chinese they're pulled back from
investigating chinese financial crimes
and ripping off billions of dollars from
american individual investors i mean one
could go on the maxwell client list i
could go on too so yeah absolutely i
just needed to interrupt you
because i know that there's one person
at this table that's been to epstein
island
that's correct
myself
very carefully i i didn't go as yeah i'm
tired
so i love introducing luke to people and
i'm like he's been epstein island
and then everyone just gives him this
look like
cyanide look at this what was it like
what was it like creepy
extremely creepy very
i was sweating running around trying to
videotape as much as i could very bad
juju very bad energy just to clarify
stormed the island after the fact to
film and document what you know was
there
not he was not an invited guest yes an
amphibious assault yeah that's right ran
out of there got chased out but you got
to see the look on people's faces when
i'm like oh looks been epstein island
and i don't even the first time you did
you caught me i was like yeah whatever
and then and then he started looking at
me i just anyway so you're a democrat
all the democrats visited there not
always i mean there were i mean if you
look at a lot of the people it's
bipartisan when it comes to the larger
trafficking and extortion operation that
was pretty much run by epstein a lot of
republicans a lot of democrats i mean
a lot of people intricately involved in
our current political system even trump
appointees that had to resign because of
them giving the sweetheart deal to of
course epstein and
and letting him get away from for
horrible horrible crimes and the fbi
also most notably was interviewing
victims of of his all the way in the 90s
and the fbi chose to ignore the victims
not help the victims that were coming
forward as police officers federal
agents prosecutors were all looking away
and and essentially aiding and abetting
into what was was hurting children in
unspeakable ways that we can't even
describe here on this broadcast so we
have a pattern here absolutely if you
look at the gymnastic investigation that
went nowhere too exactly and the client
list still wasn't released and galen
maxwell went down for a crime where she
had no clients you know which is
absolutely mind-boggling
she was just like trafficking kids into
like a boat and then kicking out the
water walking away
but we could talk about intelligence
agency corruption all day
i think it's interesting to see what's
happening from the inside especially
from the intelligence committees that's
why you know i asked you without that
question how this is playing out what's
happening here is
what do you think is the motive here is
it legitimately investigating a crime or
do you think this is
something bigger something something
more of a conspiracy yeah i don't know
how you know we can get into this right
now um maybe talk about it later too but
we thought at least when when we
unraveled the russia hoax at the very
beginning so we're talking 2017 and 18
we thought at that point
that we had been able to
effectively
kind of solder the the wound stop the
bleeding you know molar the molar
nonsense with heart with um
his top lawyer uh andrew wiseman
we thought okay we stopped all that barr
came in durham came in
and i'm sure we'll get to the durham
investigation at some point too
but we thought at least the lovebirds
were gone struck page all of that
and ray was at least saying the right
things that there'll be some healing
period we're trying to do everything
right he always said the right things
but clearly what it what has happened is
that there has been a
a gestapo like get trump crew that's
been created
within the national security division
of the department of justice and the fbi
and look we kind of know that now
because if you were involved in the
russia hoax the pre-planning and the
implementation in 15 and 16 you now got
a promotion and you're at the top levels
of the department of justice right now
so so that really happened
and then you know this whole
tbu guy that came out that was escorted
out a couple weeks ago fbi guy
uh you know he what they're doing is
they're running it with the national
security division and this and this is
important for the audience to know
there's a division in there called
counter intelligence
and
the way the rules and the regs work is
within counter intelligence they're able
to wall everything everybody off within
the fbi dha say oh counterintelligence
investigation can't talk about it you
know and that's how they effectively hid
a lot of this from us
which i will probably get into this
later but that's why and why i made the
joke at the outset
this is why they brought dan chenko who
was the
fake phony russian source for the
dossier
it's why the fbi brought him in was to
hide him from congress hide him from our
investigation you know what your biggest
challenge is
there is so much to understand to
unravel everything that's happening
that the average person can't absorb it
in a few minutes right you know that's
why i came into the show because it's
like two hours plus two hours so we'll
just get a list of names we'll go
through it we'll give everyone's bio
have you ever seen those crazy maps like
the charts i was gonna say let's get the
bulletin board out there and the plants
right
with all the players wow
the the crime web with the red red yarn
or whatever oh yeah it's actually quite
good and it's important to understand
it's not just the fbi here as you
mentioned but the fbi also influencing
the corporate media and large
institutions like wikipedia and the
washington post that were playing
defense for the intelligence agencies
regurgitating everything they were
saying criticizing attacking you for
calling out the clear lies clearing out
and then also journalists i was listed
on a washington post uh story as as fake
russian news because i didn't believe i
i wanted to see evidence of this russian
collusion i said okay if you think that
there was russian collusion let's let's
present us with some evidence but we
can't believe the intelligence agencies
since of course they lie routinely to
the american people they lied about wmds
they lied about so many different things
that i could mention here iran contra we
could actually keep going on and on and
on and i was like there's no reason to
believe these guys because of that i was
pulling on a list i was ostracized and i
was de-personed from wikipedia for even
asking questions well now what they've
become very good at is they just control
the whole process so you know not too
far away from here uh in you know in the
washington dc beltway it's become bigger
and bigger and bigger and colonel harvey
can tell you
that that's been probably the biggest
downfall we created this this new
superstructure after 9 11. we brought a
lot more bureaucracy in a lot more
bureaucrats and we're so much less
focused on actually you know finding and
taking care of of hard targets that are
definitely a dangerous united states
and everything can now be manipulated
because remember the quick answer for
everything now is
we're going to have a dni do a report
well of course if it's a report that
supports the the democrats or the left
it always comes out exactly the way that
they want it to come out and of course
if it's a report that
actually goes after the democrats for
their you know whatever it may be like
for the rush oaks for example it took
the inspector general two years to come
out with this then it took durham to be
appointed and now durham's had two
indictments and now we're still waiting
yeah there was a new york times article
about that today saying that the durham
report is not going to lead to anything
substantial do you think the new york
times perspective on it is correct or
would you question that new article that
just came out i don't know if you're
aware of the article well i don't read
fake news
and so i i actually don't even push on
you know the websites except you know if
they attack me
then i'll evaluate it and and see what
it is but but look i've actually and
colonel harvey maybe has a different
opinion than me but
i've actually been very supportive of
the durham investigation because it's
the only investigation that i've seen in
my entire two decades that i spent in
washington
with zero leaks
and that gives me quite a bit of
confidence and he's and he's got to a
lot of information that we didn't even
get to
one of the things the new york times
gets its information from fbi sources
the fbi uses new york times washington
post they put a story out there and then
they use that story in the new york
times
to start an investigation it's amazing
absolutely and it's it goes like that
and there's that relationship
you guys talk about it all the time on
the show you guys talk about narrative
building yeah oh yeah yeah that's all it
is man
i'm interested to see what happens with
the derm investigation but i gotta be
honest it's taken so long we haven't
seen a whole lot that
i don't know i don't have a lot of faith
but i wonder
if maybe the reason we're seeing them go
so heavily now after trump allies these
40 subpoenas could it be because they're
worried they're running out of time well
look if you want to let's talk about the
mar-a-lago raid because see you know all
roads you can give you know keep it
simple all roads basically lead back to
russia gate i mean pretty much all roads
lead to russiagate right even the
impeachment hoax on you know on ukraine
was still russiagate same players
so if if you've had cash patel on the on
this show before
so the one thing that we learned
throughout our investigation is is that
the
fbi doj they love to use fake news
to
go into their affidavits into their
warrants
well
the first thing i noticed when i read
that affidavit and you know the
inspector general has said you shouldn't
do it and then when that when the when
they released the warrant then the
affidavit
there was two stories essentially that
was all that was the only thing
unredacted were two news stories now
i've never seen fbi doj in all my time
ever use a breitbart story right because
they consider breitbart to be fake news
but for the first time in my life they
used breitbart right
and in it was cash patel
and cash patel they completely take what
he says out of context what he says is
that he's seen the intelligence reports
relating to the russia hoax that were
that were declassified and we've never
seen
they basically misconstrue that we don't
see everything below it but what cash is
clearly talking about there is he's
talking about
the documents that i've seen derek seen
we've all seen we didn't see him at
mar-a-lago we saw him when we were in
congress or we at the they were you know
or at the white house we saw all those
documents they're supposed to be
declassified they're using that out of
context they're using to just to play
these games
and the other story of course was a
local news agency that saw some white
vans pull into monologue
yeah yeah moving boxes or something yes
back to durham real quick tim
you know i i worry that durham is going
after people like deshenko and
kleinsmith for false
document
issues
but he's not going to go after
the root of the problem which is in the
fbi itself
the trump sleeper cell
or maybe not it's the national security
division yeah and
they're enablers over at the doj
how worried should we be i mean are we
going to see republicans win in november
then maybe do something about this or
are they not going to do anything until
the executive branch changes
look i i think for the first time
uh that i've seen people are really
pissed off
out there i mean just you know if i
travel across the country and you see it
i mean people are really really
concerned and they should be i mean i
would have never i can't say that it
that it shocked me
that they raided mar-a-lago
but man this is really banana republic
time i want to i want to show you guys
this story from the daily news because
it's kind of silly but it's also kind of
freaky hardy's seizes on mike lindell's
fbi drama to sell pillowy biscuits
no joke
the fast food chain what is this hardy
har har thanks daily news fast food jane
hardy's seized on being included in the
headlines about alleged confiscation of
my pillow's ceo mike lindell cell phone
with an ad promoting something the
bombastic businessman might enjoy
now that you know we exist you should
really try our pillowy biscuits
lindell a spirited conspiracy theorist
has worked tirelessly blah blah blah the
point here is
we're at the point where fast food
chains are making memes of the collapse
of of our country to sell
fast food
those biscuits are a little tasteless
in my opinion
but uh you know i make jokes references
to gulags just kind of being
sensationalistic and hyperbolic but
am i that far away i mean where do you
see the the road ending with this
because we see the groundwork being laid
down by hillary clinton by joe biden by
kamala harris by
congressman
tim ryan today saying very hyperbolic
statements against you know the mega
republicans where does this end because
i think they just started and i think
they're just laying down the groundwork
for something very serious that could be
very dangerous for everyone the white
house spokesperson said that if you
disagree with them you're an extremist
okay yeah and they are trying to
criminalize all political disagreement
yeah look i'm a
i'm a happy warrior and so i don't want
us to all
go out and jump out of the building here
you know i just think that this is
but it is very very serious without
question you know we are a time when
when where we've never been in this
country
and i think if people don't take it
seriously which i think they are across
the country but i can guarantee you the
beltway
doesn't understand what's going on they
don't understand the anger when you get
out to the this i mean look you're not
very far outside of oh it's it's my
country
and you can tell i mean you know people
i was i was at an event earlier tonight
i mean
people are scared people are pissed and
and and that's what's happening so you
have essentially a split in this country
it's not so much red states blue states
it's city-states
versus the rest of america so it just
depends like here in maryland you know
it's a blue state largely because
baltimore right right and and the outs
the suburbs of washington dc everywhere
else red and getting redder and the same
the same thing is is true in in my part
of california uh where i'm from you know
i'm halfway between la and san francisco
so look
i want to be positive i want to believe
in the constitution i want to but you
know clearly
you know look i left congress
you know not because i i you know i
needed a new job and trump didn't need a
new company but it's pretty bad when i
got to leave congress solely because i
believe that the communications
platforms are so broken that we have no
way to get our message out we can't even
communicate with one another and we're
in the middle of a propaganda war that's
destroying this country where it's
pushing
city states getting moving hard left and
everybody else moving hard right and
that heart in the in the in the you know
when i say hard right meaning you know
conservative where they can't even
communicate with one another and we're
constantly dealing with with fake news
and censorship i don't even think it's
moving hard right i mean my politics are
basically in the same spot they've
always been except on second amendment
i think for a lot of people especially
people in my situation it's that the
left has just continually gone further
and further left elon musk posted that
meme you saw it i'd imagine where do you
see this one it's like left and right
and then years later left to move but
he's staying in the same spot and it's
just moving further and further left the
left likes to use that and say see this
proves it
if you still believe the same things you
did 10 years ago you are conservative
you're traditionalists you're not
progressive that's their argument so
they're actually saying yeah we agree
with that you are now on the right it
has changed but i got to tell you man
what's really scary is
i know people
that uh i used to consider friends
and they've gone insane
they've actually gone insane the things
they believe they believe every hoax
from the media they believe justice
millet oops that was a hoax they believe
the russiagate stuff they believe hands
up don't shoot they believe the armoury
story they believe the trayvon martin
stuff they believed all of that
and even after all of it the covington
catholic kids even after all of that is
debunked and the media they still
believe it
we know those stories are fake they
still believe the lies every day right
and they're full of anger is the crazy
thing the messages i see on on on
facebook you know there's a few people
i've known my whole life who still like
they're they're very liberal they're
very anti-trump but they still talk to
me and they say listen to me and they go
oh i don't know that good friends but i
know some people that
they've gone nuts and i'm wondering if
you guys have experienced the same thing
like people who've become totally just
i don't even want to say trump
derangement it's like
it's it's
right-wing derangement but it's not even
that it's if you're outside of the cult
they just believe whatever they're told
by the media yeah well maybe a good
example for
you is this
so when i when i went when i was elected
to congress 2002
bernie sanders was in the house of
representatives a lot of people
forgot that that he was actually a
member of the house for a very long time
and i remember
a lot of the first votes i'd look up on
the screen you know there's always a lot
of votes and you know a lot of them are
are a lot of bills that they get get
through they don't always become law but
they're you know sometimes they're just
messaging bills but you would have
something like
you know baseball and apple pie some
feel good thing and you'd look up on the
screen and there'd be like 20 notebooks
like okay and then who are those people
and it would be bernie sanders and this
hard left
wing
caucus
and it was constantly they were like you
know equivalent of back benchers like
you would see in a parliamentary system
where they just didn't have any friends
nobody really took them serious the
democrats laughed at them
right because at that point i had
friends on the other side of the aisle
people that i would talk to and that oh
that's the crazy people you know
and now
they're in charge they're in charge and
there's i mean there's not 20
that aren't
you know full-fledged marxists
in one way or wow or at least they have
to pretend that they are and that's
really what this is it's all about power
it's all about how do you get and keep
and hold power and that's what i saw
during my time in washington and i got
to the point where
like when i i knew we were in trouble
and you know i was one of the first guys
to go to parlor and i was one of the
first guys to go to rumble because i
caught
the
fake news and the
and the social media companies shadow
banning me so i went to these new
platforms because and i and i realized
quickly like man i grew like followers
like no tomorrow and then of course
parlor got nuked by the by big tech yeah
and crazy the rest is history how was
that legal it was it was it was
collusion it was it was it had to be
some kind of you know there's got to be
some kind of anti-trust action or
something to stop this kind of collusion
in the market yeah but then they went to
court i don't know where those cases are
now but you have to go in many cases
they go to court in their home in their
home court so even the court this has
even reached the courts but where's the
doj and the fbi investigating this and
subpoenaing and going in and
confiscating
cell phones and computers and laptops
okay to build a case to look for the
crime to look for the crime yeah well
look we had i mean look it ultimately
ends up with
supreme court justices something leaking
unprecedented history a decision
pre-leaks out
right that we still haven't got to the
bottom of and then they're out
protesting and threatening supreme court
justices homes which should be illegal
when it comes from you know all the work
you've done who has more influence and
power the intelligence agencies or big
tech social media and do the
intelligence agencies affect big tech
social media
so so remember the intelligence agencies
aren't what is is corrupt here
it is the
the people at the high echelons of the
democratic party operandis
that are running those intelligence
agencies
right so they control all the levers of
power does that make sense this is not
it's the democrats and the democrats are
then sending messaging
to the fake news right because all the
fake news they'll come out boom one day
narratives out there over and over again
they they pound away
and then
but then you know it's tough to tell
with it and then trump was in office and
then the intelligence agencies were
working against him
so you know
yeah yeah because because he didn't
control no
that's kind of when a republican we have
no we have no power i mean when
republicans get in they can't control it
anymore it's like an it's it's because
what happens is they put their people in
they burrow them in
right
you're saying that the fb that these
intelligence agencies or at least parts
of them have gone rogue
well
the reason no they're just yeah they've
been they don't answer to the
commander-in-chief then oh yeah they've
basically gone rogue
they've recruited and they've promoted
and retained people that fit a political
narrative that come from a certain type
of school that think a certain way that
reflect the woke agenda and
in this last congress we saw the
democrats trying to push that type of
woke recruitment
and ideological perspective throughout
more of the intelligence agencies okay
mandating it
and look part of the reason why is it
it's it's hard to get we talked about
city states a little bit ago it's hard
to get republicans to say boy i'd really
like to go make a career and live in
washington dc and burrow myself in get
connected go to the brookings institute
write reports go work for congress
become a lobbyist and always working i
mean republicans for the most part don't
want to do that
right they want to live in rural
maryland right or they want to live in
in you know rural america but just back
to the question who has more power and
influence
well i would say that they're all one i
guess is the short answer yeah no
they're they're all kind of one you're
absolutely right yeah you're absolutely
right that's something i've been saying
for for years now and a lot of people
don't understand that there really isn't
much of a difference when it comes to
the decisions the major ones that they
make well now now we're getting uh
evidence in these these lawsuits that
the the federal government was
instructing directing big tech to censor
people they didn't like right right and
it's been a cascade we've gotten a
little bit here and now it's now it's
full swing now we've got emails where
alex berenson is that's the name that's
a journalist right yeah where they're
like why hasn't he been banned yet
twitter and then twitter's like okay and
then he gets banned
dr fouchy parody accounts got hit
because the white house demonstrates
them too that is absolutely crazy hey i
think you guys i might have heard you
guys talking about this a bit but
there's some yeah and this sounds
ridiculous because you know
you know but i'm a you know guy that's
been in political business and now and
now uh you know running through social
so i i'm not attuned to this stuff like
you guys are but i had never heard of
this guy named andrew tate
okay yeah i'd never heard of the guy
before right i mean until like a few
weeks ago
and how is it possible it's it's very
similar to the parlor thing right where
overnight parlor boom gets nuked by 30
40 companies right they get cancelled by
everyone
well the same thing i never heard his
andrew tate guy but
it's so odd that everybody canceled them
like he got nuked from every platform
within within what 48 hours yep it's
collusion
they they all live in the same area they
all work in the same area yes emails pro
processors website everything got taken
away from him i want to talk to you guys
about the fake news because this is uh
this is a really funny story and we have
the ability to debunk it um we have the
story from the times dot uk quote just
like a mob meeting what trump's curious
golf course confeds that's tongue's
wagging what was this donald trump
having a secret meeting on a golf course
with no golf clubs i wonder who was at
the secret meeting well newsweek reports
something about uh rumors that those who
joined trump at the course of course
were minority leader kevin mccarthy of
fox news sean hannity and former
congressman turned ceo of truth social
devin nunes wait a minute well that's
just rumors what about this
raw story correction a previous version
of the story alleges that devin nunes
kevin mccarthy oh okay all right well
what about this daily dot
you know the daily dot just points out
with a with a tweet they don't actually
state it themselves
he has been he has not been photographed
golfing he's photographed with mccarthy
nunes eric trustee hannity and others
standing in the rain on a golf course
with no clubs and no golf shoes
apparently that tweet was enough to get
raw story to report that it was a fact
and for newsweek to run the rumor that
these people were there
this would have to mean
uh mr nunes that you can in fact
teleport yes actually i'm there if you
look in the tree see that picture there
in the tree in the tree if you just look
behind there i know yeah you can't there
yeah yeah yeah that's me yeah that's it
yeah yeah so
see they were close but wrong so um this
is funny because this story went viral
they claimed all these people were there
you weren't there
no in fact it was it was so i was
actually commuting from california back
back east and i was actually headed to
washington dc
and i had a long delay in dallas
at the dallas airport i got you know
like everybody's getting now but i ended
up supposed to be there two hours i was
there like six hours so you're in dallas
um how did you feel when you found out
you were actually in dc on a golf course
well that's at night all of a sudden my
phone blows up with these stories
and then i'm like what in the hell is
this
and then i'm reading and i don't even
know what the hell's going on and i'm
trying to get you know i'm trying to get
on and then i get on the airplane and
then and then i fly and then i don't get
into washington until like it was
actually 2 30 when i landed uh a.m
and the next morning my phone is blowing
up i'm like what in the hell is this so
yeah i was clearly right there in those
trees yeah so i was i could i was at in
dallas and there at the same time
magical well people need to understand
that the issue is if you if you jumped
from dallas to dc then the paladins
would track you down um
tracing your jump scar and uh you know
be very dangerous for for jumpers like
devon what's that from it's from jumper
okay okay
people can teleport yeah i wonder who
got that reference hayden christiansen i
think was in it he was the main guy
right i don't know that movie i was
thinking of the the dude from the x-men
that could teleport morph no no not more
nightcrawler what i think morph why did
i say that yeah he was a good character
by the way i don't know he only made it
in like a couple of the x-men movies
nightcrawler yeah oh yeah yeah his fight
scene in x-men 2 was awesome fighting
and teleporting at the same time yeah so
this is amazing but he like disappeared
like he's not he he wasn't in the
last the last movies
i is he not in it they rebooted it and
they saw him like i think he might be
you know come yeah he's a good character
are they going to bring him back i have
no idea
well did you know colonel harvey is like
a nightcrawler too oh yeah that's right
that's right yeah because you guys were
able to this was a bigger jump you went
from uh for from where from italy or
from where were you we were uh
we were meeting dirty russians and
ukrainians and where were we
vienna we're in vienna yes wow
so okay yes
so the media claims
the story's still up by the way you can
go to cnn the story's up i'm not not
making this up you can and the crazy
left believes it yep yeah it's still up
it hasn't been taken down it's blue and
on there it is oh is this one the
giuliani associate willing to tell
congress nunes met with ex-ukrainian
officials get dirt and biden yep that's
the one this is this is amazing it's
amazing these journalists don't bother
asking you they just run it i mean i'm
saying that more rhetorically i don't
know if they literally called you over
this but i've dealt with stories
what happens is one journalist will
write a fake story
they'll wait 15 minutes and then redact
they'll stealth edit it but by then all
the other outlets will have already
picked it up and take plausible
deniability and say
we weren't uh there's no actual malice
we were just repeating what you know nbc
or what this other outlet said yeah so
we assumed it was true i would love to
go to vienna austria i've never been
there ever well we know we know this so
so this story actually
so these guys so i i sued cnn
and they skated right and so the fake
news will report that i lost this
lawsuit but they what they do is they
use technicalities and so they they got
a judge
to agree
that even though this all occurred and
it impacted me in washington dc
you know with intelligence overseas
and how they got out of it is they said
that no california law applied and i
didn't do my retraction notice in time
that's how they got out of this that's
why that story is still alive cnn's
california-based
no no no
unprecedented never been done before
california a judge ultimately got
transferred the case got long story but
it got transferred to new york in a in a
new york judge democrat appointed judge
said for the first time that i know of
that california law applies to me even
though i was a federal official chairman
of the house intelligence committee in
washington that's how they get out of it
it's not just that it's that the story
is that giuliani associate is willing to
tell congress that you did this and
they're like well that's a factual
statement it doesn't mean it actually
happened it means someone is willing to
say it happened that is
you know how it works i love that i love
this you'll get a story and it'll say
source close to nancy pelosi's office
claims that you know she's planning to
meet with vladimir putin or donald trump
or something and then people go oh wow
oh wow a source close to her office and
the source close to her office is a
homeless guy sleeping in the alley huh
he is close to her office that was all
true can't sue him for fake news because
it's literally the truth well this is an
affirmative defense the funny thing
about this guy is though this guy
these cnn and these reporters so this is
a guy named uh pornos harness parnasse
who who you know he he had tried to like
so so colonel harvey was my investigator
right so when people would have
you know when they would have things
that they want us to look at and you
know we would take all comers right so
derek would have to meet everyone well
this guy came to us and said oh he had
all kinds of information of course he
didn't have anything
and so derek met with him a couple times
and then this guy he was described by
cnn as a wolf in sheep's clothing so
they know he's a he's a liar he's now in
jail by the way yeah he's now in jail
and this guy went on and the democrats
would repeat this garbage right about me
about derek
and and they knew so when you talk about
teleporting we were in we were actually
it's kind of funny
uh when we later were able to say this
because i filed it in court
we were actually in libya
so
the so what must have happened is they
leaked that they knew we were on
international travel because we were
traveling on behalf of the government
and we were the first we were the first
delegates someone from hipste leaked it
probably adam shifts people yeah but we
were in we were actually in libya
meeting with half tar pretty damn
dangerous place we're in benghazi wow we
were in benghazi and these bastards run
this story and they run this story you
know to to just to just dirty aside and
they didn't bother asking you
um you know i don't even remember if
they did or i think they asked for an
interview but what i do after 17
after 2017 when they accused me of being
a russian agent like if you accuse me of
being a russian agent
like until you retract that story i
don't talk to you yeah and was like i'm
not going to talk to them and with love
paranas i investigated i looked at all
the information made a few inquiries
over a period of like six weeks because
it wasn't constant it's just
intermittent over a period of time
because you got a lot of stuff going on
and i came to dev and i said this is a
dead end this guy's not trustworthy yeah
and then and then they release this is i
don't know if you guys remember this is
when
schiff released my phone records that's
right and and and um also john solomon
too right yeah a bunch of people he
released a bunch of previous phone
numbers yeah so
we couldn't you know if you call back in
the day and then this is how all members
of congress i think if they're doing
their job if somebody calls in like if
you were to call in to your
congressman's office
today
you know hopefully you would get a call
back within two or three days
and so the port so in this case poor
harvey was you know this guy calls in i
tell harvey to call the guy
and then all of a sudden you know these
phone records are released as if
harvey's now done something bad because
he's just calling somebody back that had
information that said was relevant
that's his job yeah that's crazy that he
released the private information of a
journalist
yeah how about me his colleague well
yeah yeah no of course of course
but you know
yeah john solomon on by the way
no no no no no yeah well he's he's great
how was the trip to libya though
right that place isn't really uh known
for its uh international visitors
how would you describe it it kind of
looked like a hellscape a little surreal
a little surreal i mean slavery it kind
of looked when we landed there there was
like well the russians were on one side
of the airport yeah strong start and um
and then but it did look like i thought
i saw the devil out there with like a
pitchfork and a sign that said welcome
to hell
now we've got the conspiracy we're we're
working with the russians we really went
to benghazi to work with the russians
there you go you heard it here well now
you're admitting it yeah
how did russia come to be the villain
you know like is it because of the
pipeline is it because of gaza promised
because of ukraine because i i certainly
think china's a bigger thing they loved
russia okay so this is the this is the
dam like everybody asked me like how did
you know
that the russia stuff was was nonsense
it was really easy and of course the
fake news has ignored this the whole
time
so
in
2013 or 12 13 14
the russians were pushing obama around
remember i'm on the intelligence
committee
i worked really closely with with our
eastern european allies like poland and
romania and others and remember the
russians like suddenly they were in
libya doing everything suddenly they
were in
syria doing things suddenly they
overtake crimea with little green men so
so i'm involved in all this
and
we couldn't get
the obama administration to do a damn
thing
you know they would not do
anything uh to the
you know to the russians they just
wouldn't deal with them so you can
imagine so in two that in the in the
spring of 2016
and just for your time the time
reference this is when
the obama biden administration are
working with the clinton campaign that
begin investigating trump and
republicans to tie them to russia okay i
have no idea that's going on
but in the spring of 2016
i went out and made which is a really
you know
important statement at the time the
chairman of the house intelligence
committee said look the biggest
intelligence failure since 9 11 is our
failure to understand putin's plans and
intentions
so this is the biggest intelligence
fighter since then so i say that at the
same time that they are painting us
with being some kind of russian agent so
you can imagine after the election when
they come and say oh the russians were
trying to help trump in a republican
what the hell are you talking about you
guys haven't done any damn thing about
russia i said this is a lie i've never
seen because i i was actually paying
attention to what putin was doing they
weren't yeah well putin was building his
sphere of influence and alliance with
the syrian government but when barack
obama was in power there's even serious
talks of barack obama potentially
launching an invasion or an attack on
syria and then it was general flynn that
came out and actually whistleblowed and
talked about how the united states was
funding radical islamists inside of that
region and i think there's been a
massive payback against him for that so
there's a lot of uh also complicated
geopolitical uh maneuvers in all of this
if you remember i remember the russians
also intervened and sent their
battleships to prevent u.s warships from
being off the coast of syria from
potentially launching more missile
strikes i remember there was protests
there um
what do you remember for that what do
you remember from that time because a
lot of people thought we were very close
to a war with syria i i think you're i
think you're actually missing one of the
most important
uh data points
do you remember the time that that obama
leaned over before the election when he
was running against mitt romney and and
at the time uh he was talking to the
russian president which i can't think of
his name now
madrid and he says and he's on a hot mic
and he says yeah tell vladimir till i
have to wait till after the election you
know or something like that i'll have
more flexibility more flexibility
yeah i mean that's the biggest issue
collusion yeah
i love the the classification narrative
they're doing now
because the implication is the president
doesn't have the ability to declassify
documents unilaterally
and the point i make is imagine the
president the united states meeting with
the the president of russia
and them saying it's time to negotiate a
de-escalation of these nuclear weapons
and he goes i wish i could but i don't
have the ability to classify what our
weapons are so i can't tell you it's
classified sorry maybe there's some
higher authority in the united states
that can tell me what i'm allowed to
tell you and then we'll negotiate that's
an insane prospect
well that's what we dealt with i mean
that's why
people have to remember in 2017
we knew nearly right away i just went
through the story of how i knew why i
knew i knew they were full of [ __ ] but i
definitely knew
that this was a problem when i found out
that the clinton campaign
you know had paid for this dossier
and you know how long it's crazy you
know how long it took for us to get that
out to the public
we knew that for nine months and you
couldn't release it no if you remember
they were trying to investigate me yeah
remember they put me under an ethics
investigation
remember that they were going after all
of my team all of our lawyers everyone
so they were looking for any way and
remember trump is under investigation by
mueller the mueller witch hunt crew
so i mean they've got an army
of g-men doj
with a special counsel authority i'm
sitting there in congress with under
investigation because they said i was
leaking leaking intelligence it took us
that long to get that information out to
the public and if you go back in time if
you remember in that february time frame
of 2018 remember they said he's gonna
people are gonna die if nunes releases
this memo it's gonna be horrible and
then like the next day it came out oh
this is no big deal the clinton campaign
everybody knew that
you know
they did the fake news did know that the
clinton campaign but none of us knew the
american public didn't know the
attitudes tim is so similar to remember
vinman when he was testifying and he
basically said that the engineer is the
audience of vinman you got to know
vinman was the lieutenant colonel
whistleblower yeah you know complainer
that led to the ukrainian impeachment
issue and he thought it was so important
that the president was possibly
betraying
you know and doing things that the
interagency didn't want vinman said
that the interagency
dictates what the president should be
doing that's not the president who
determines foreign policy it's the
interagency
yeah that's crazy do you think that
vendeman is a useful idiot or do you
think he's willfully malicious
both both i was going to say an idiot
who's malicious
that's crazy the uh he's not smart
enough to be like he's not very talented
but he's definitely a useful idiot well
they wanted him to be the minister of
defense for ukraine
yeah according to him getting ready for
which but that's what shows you is a
useful idiot
those ukrainians they thought here's a
dumb ass that we can bribe let's tell
him that we want him to be the
the
what do you guys think about the uh
uh joe biden the you know if the
prosecutor's not fired
that that whole thing i mean do you guys
do you guys know stuff that we don't
i've done uh quite a bit of uh
research into the whole ukraine gate
scandal and it really does seem like
right now especially with hunter biden's
laptop
that uh joe biden's involved in illicit
business dealings that he's using his
son as a proxy that's what it seems like
and i have to wonder now with the the
billions that are being dumped into
ukraine is this joe biden paying good on
his debts i knew you were russian asset
that's what i was saying oh yeah yeah
you're repeating russian disinformation
yeah i love i just real quick i love how
politico reported i think it was in
early 2017 that ukrainian officials
colluded uh to help the democrats win
the election were embarrassed and
scrambling now that donald trump won and
then a few years later their one of
their reporters said actually that story
was russian disinformation yet they
still haven't retracted the initial
report how can your outlet
simultaneously report both things yeah
amazing i mean look they haven't
retracted that report the one that's
still up on the screen there yeah real
quick and barisma timeline i'd just like
to run through it real quick for you
because i think it matters about the the
call for firing the prosecutor
the white house under under obama had a
conference with ukrainian
officials
in late january
and on the offside of that conference at
the old executive office building they
were addressing corruption and they
asked the state prosecutor
representatives there to back off the
barissima investigation
a week later
back in ukraine they conducted a raid of
the barisma headquarters and the
president of the barisma company's home
that led to at least eight phone calls
over the next 10 days between
president biden
and president porchenko of ukraine which
then subsequently led to a trip
coordinated by eric chiramela
to ukraine
where they put the the hammer down
saying we need the investigation of
barissimo ended
they masked it under
corruption saying that the attorney
the state's attorney was corrupt
that's when they threatened
to withhold imf funding
that same prosecutor that they're asking
to be fired for corruption had gotten an
award from the united states at the end
of 2015 for being a stellar prosecutor
yeah i mean look if we would have
you know the hunter buying laptop i mean
if
if if you and i and your team here
decide tonight that we're just going to
start doing crack cocaine bringing some
prostitutes or whatever the fbi would be
knocking on your door tomorrow morning
yeah lying on our taxes lying on the
government uh gun forms throwing a gun
in the garbage outside of a school
behind us
here do some crack
they'll be here in 24 hours here's
here's a big story that's uh almost uh
what's over five years old now almost
six years old from politico ukrainian
efforts to sabotage trump backfire you
heard it right here from news guard
certified politico
100
yes check it out and they say ukrainian
government officials tried to help
hillary clinton and undermine trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aide in
corruption and suggested they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and they helped
clinton's allies research damaging
information on trump and his advisors a
political investigation found kenneth p
vogel and david stern
how is this story still on politico when
they later came out i think it was
politico eu is reporting from my i
believe it could be wrong natasha
bertrand saying this story was in fact
russian disinformation yet it's still up
right now yeah and we we derek and i we
know a lot about this uh this story
because we brought this story up over
and over and over again during the
ukraine impeachment hoax i mean this is
one of the stories that proves that it's
a hoax the whole the whole first
impeachment of trump was a hoax
it was i mean
they accused trump of what they had done
exactly
so joe biden i love this we had a we had
a guest on the show i'll i'll give him
the courtesy of
not saying his name but people know who
it was with this younger guy he was like
a
anti-woke guy and then he went liberal
and we're sitting down we're talking to
him and i said joe biden sitting at his
meeting what was it luke was it atlantic
council or was it cfr um
with uh joe biden talking about yeah the
thing yep that was cfr cfr richard
the president of the cfo he's like
encyclopedia on these meetings cfr bad
bad people
so joe biden says i told them if you
don't fire the prosecutor you're not
getting the billion dollars and they
said what you can't you have no
authorities to call the president see
what he says six is i look at my watch
and you got six hours the prosecutor's
not fired you're not getting the money
well sob
i got fired and i'm like so an illegal
quid pro quo the vice president has no
authority to override
certified loan guarantees from the us
government he can't do that he did it
they accused trump of doing that trump
never asked for anything but this is
what joe biden literally did
amazing and here he is now sitting as
president yeah so donald trump
stumbles upon this in my opinion i don't
think trump knew all that much about
what was going on i think trump saw a
twitter video of joe biden saying this
that went viral because the phone call
transcript was funny he's like what is
this thing you know with biden saying
the loans you know why don't you look
into that right he didn't even know what
he was talking about and then they
probably panicked like no we can't have
him digging into that impeach impeach
it's amazing
biden was not running for office at the
time and the media ran with trump is
targeting his rival like rival joe biden
the dude it's old and not running for
office nobody thought he would i i think
some people speculated he would run but
there was no definitive answer whether
he would but that's the angle they went
with donald trump stumbled upon some
very serious corruption and i think
people need to understand this what's
happening in ukraine i think has long
been planned i was there on the ground
in in the end of 2013 and i think into
early i think it was end of 2013 when
the maidan protests were starting then
it was a few months later i had left
they ousted yanukovych
this was this was an escalation that had
been happening quite a bit russia was
takes crimea
donald trump gets elected everything
stops
donald trump loses joe biden is now
president
russia conflict ukraine starts up again
it's amazing how that happened how if
you just
use a a modicum of common sense
that when when barack obama is in office
this this conflict is escalating joe
biden is is shaking down this country
and then when trump said everything
stops yeah and it's not just biden that
was shaking it down i mean biden was one
of the top guys shaking it down but
there's there's so much so many of these
people in washington dc that represent
these countries
i mean we don't even know the half of
of of how many people were on the
payroll of these these ukrainians both
democrats and republicans i think
ukraine is what a vassal state of nato
of the united states
you know uh
you you've got russia running the
gazprom pipeline through the country
jacking up the prices into europe
causing a lot of problems the u.s wanted
to build the cutter turkey pipeline
syria said no the u.s says oh look lucky
us bashar al-assad is facing a civil war
and we just happen to support the other
people it's it's it seems very obvious
what the whole thing was really about
and why they wanted to demonize russia
over china yeah yeah i wanted to ask you
what did you think about trump's foreign
policy towards ukraine and russia
because you made some assertions about
obama being kind of soft on russia
what did you think of trump's job
how did he do because he was also the
first president to send lethal weapons
to ukraine which some people at the time
saw as an escalation
yeah well look
if you look at what if you look at what
trump let's talk about the big picture
and back up and then go back to the
propaganda
so remember every time trump would make
a move
they would say he's an idiot oh i can't
believe he said that this is
embarrassing
and you know a lot of us were sitting
back saying well wait a second you know
we've been having these you know i would
go to these meetings and you know i i
spent a lot of time overseas i mean
colonel harvey was was with me at a lot
of these meetings and we would go meet
with some anywhere from our allies to
okay people to some really bad people
you know
and
i was just glad for the first time
because you know i was always as a
as a
you know chair of a committee and and
top republican you know you never want
to go we always kind of had a rule that
you know the
the partisanship stops once we once we
leave the country right and you try to
put forth you know good faith effort
overseas so you know with republicans
democrats you don't want to be fighting
your political conflicts over there just
makes for confusion
and you know i'd sit in those damn
meetings with i remember specifically
sitting in a meeting with the germans
knowing that they were that they were
shutting down their nuclear power plants
and they were they were getting ready to
put this pipeline additional pipeline in
to be solely relying on
russia and i was thinking to myself and
i always kick myself sometimes when you
think i should have said something i
should have done something
and um and not that it would have
mattered at the time but i said you know
you know i felt like saying what the
hell are you guys doing you know and
sometimes i'd have little sidebars like
what what what the hell you guys doing
with this you guys are shutting down
these nuclear power plants this is this
is crazy so when trump
goes over there and says okay cut all
this [ __ ] out here's what we're
gonna here's what we're gonna do
why are you buying these why why are you
putting this pipeline why are you
shutting down your nuclear power plants
you guys are crazy why aren't you
putting in the money to nato i mean how
many times i would go to nato and we'd
sit there in these stupid meetings and
everybody you know oh you know i can
only put in 1.2 percent i'm supposed to
put in two i mean this has gone on for
three or four decades of these guys not
putting in their money
yeah
and so what trump remember like that was
just
like what he said
was not crazy it was actually just
common sense but they should be paying
and they shouldn't be shutting down
their nukes and they shouldn't be buying
gas from russia because if you do
and the russians decide to ultimately
shut off your gas
now what the hell are they going to do
now they got a hell of a mess i mean
look this thing could get really bad
but in in germany in in in europe this
could get really bad if the russians
decide to shut this gas off here in the
next two months it's going to get bad
because they use winter as a weapon but
trump offered american natural gas you
want gas we'll provide it to you
he provided
eastern europeans especially the polls
military assistance and
you know weapon systems and things that
the obama administration had been
denying built relationships with romania
and other countries okay
he focused on russia doing things that
the obama administration didn't do he
was building up nato and pressuring nato
which the democrats accused him of
dividing nato and weakening nato but he
called them out he got them to increase
funding by a hundred and forty billion
dollars
which still wasn't close to the two
percent but it was more than we had ever
gotten right i'm just imagining these
nato countries they're like i will
gladly pay you tuesday for a missile
defense system today and then every week
it's just the same thing you know that
famous line who was that guy the
cheeseburger guy you know
was it archie comics so so did you agree
with uh with trump's policy did you
think he did a good job when it came to
navigating russia ukraine in that
situation the way it's unfolding right
now and and more importantly yeah i mean
i think look probably the best thing
that he did uh overall was how he dealt
with china yeah
i mean when he said he was going to put
in those tariffs
i thought to myself oh [ __ ] i've heard
i've heard this every you know i've been
around watching every president oh we're
gonna really get tough on china and i'll
be down if you didn't do it but but
specifically where we are now and
especially your work on the intelligence
committee how dangerous is the current
situation that we're in now especially
with this kind of proxy war between the
east and the west unfolding in ukraine
right now
um
it kind of depends on
it's tough to get good analysis out
there out of there right yeah so
look russia could do some real damage to
europe this this winter it's that's
that's a serious issue that we just
talked about
secondly it kind of depends on what i
think the russians are you know have
they lost thirty thousand fifty thousand
a hundred thousand who knows what the
right number is
um
but you know the russians clearly
thought they were going to go in their
march to kiev and that the ukrainians
were going to lay down their guns and i
will tell you that i mean
there's
i think number one it's hard for them to
no matter how much they censor
there's still a lot of young people that
they're that really they're conscripts
that the russians are relying on but you
know they know that they know ukrainians
they know each other the ukrainians
never want to have the russians back i
mean they know what it was like the old
i mean you have a lot of the old the
guys that are fighting for the
ukrainians right now
are guys that were that were in the
russian military i mean you got guys
that are 40 50 60 years old
that were brought up and trained you
know by the soviets that are now running
their military operations the russians
are relying on a lot of conscript
they've lost if look let's just call it
what do you think they lost 50 000
probably for sure probably that's that's
killed
we're not talking about all casualties
but they lost 1000 would mean what 200
250 000 casualties
i'm not sure it's that many given the
lethality on the battlefield today but
going back just a minute
the buying administration basically
invited them in to ukraine by pulling
closing down the embassy
evacuating all americans and just
basically saying
hey russia
you know we're not going to interfere
we're not going to do anything we don't
want to have any problems take what you
want
and got out of the way the fact that
zielinski in ukraine fought and the
russians were incompetent
created a stalemate and that forced
their hand and the europeans stepped up
to the plate i'm not sure who led i'm
not sure the buying administration led
on this they're going to try and take
credit for it anyway but right now one
of the issues that are being is being
talked about is was russia losing as
badly as they are
and they're they've been having some
significant setbacks on the ground
what would trigger
a tactical nuke or something else that
would potentially lead to some other
miscalculations i think he'd do it yeah
putin putin is you know and i've said
this for a long time this is you know i
had always been a russian hawk and i
would always say that anybody who
thought they were going to get along
with putin i mean it was a fool's errand
right and that goes back to clinton
george w bush mccain you you name it all
of these guys senior level and i always
disagreed putin is a thug and always
will be a thug you can only deal with
him you know with force he only
understands one thing force
and
what
so the idea that you would think that
that now and now i don't think he's
playing with a full deck i mean i didn't
think that he would go into ukraine
because i said why why would you do that
when you already know how to use a
little green men
you can do this by attrition so clearly
he's starting to he's a brilliant guy
very dangerous but he's getting
something's not right there and now
you know what the colonel said i mean
this guy could use tactical nukes i mean
i don't people i mean he's not going to
let the rest of his guys get annihilated
in ukraine and he's not going to lose
even true and people need to understand
too that when
many people imagine nuclear weapons they
imagine megaton bombs and these massive
icbms and mervs and things like that he
could be using nuclear artillery they
could use a low-yield relatively nuclear
bomb that just decimates the central
kiev
that
what would happen to the morale of the
ukrainian soldiers if putin were to fire
a nuke i think people would drop their
guns and run full speed because what do
you do at that level of war yeah and
that could eventually lead to i don't
know ukraine become i i don't i don't
believe that it would result necessarily
in mutually assured destruction
if if putin targets ukrainian strategic
locations military and
there's some fear that he'll use nuclear
power plants as standing nuclear weapons
if he targets them and uses lower yield
weapons i don't see nato or the west
responding with larger yield bombs
against russia well
putin does not want ukraine to exist if
russia does not own it
he'd like it to be a wasteland
well i think it's also important because
there's a lot of uh energy being found
especially in the southern part
especially in the in in
by odessa that the russians want to
control and that's why they concentrated
a lot of their forces a lot of their
troops on the southern because they
don't want ukraine to become a petrol
state because if ukraine becomes a
petrol state russia is absolutely
defeated and uh screwed over in the long
term and their trajectory and i think
you know there's a lot of interest here
there's a lot of energy there's a lot of
policy there's a lot of history here and
if fossil fuels are so old
yeah let's get with it let's get with
the buy administration it's old news
fossil fuels
nuclear power are they doing are they
doing that i'll take some new plants
yeah i i think it's far more complicated
but i think the situation is so
dangerous and and i see so much
escalation and and no real push for
de-escalation or peace talks and i think
it's such a complicated thing there's no
easy answer here but to me this is just
absolutely reckless on so many levels
you know i i asked luke to say today you
guys seem a little upset about this have
you considered owning nothing and being
happy
yeah no no not at all no one owe nothing
no great reset for you no uh looking
forward to just letting them
take all your belongings
if i was gonna do that i go and become a
franciscan priest
but it seems like that's the way things
are going and it makes me wonder about
if there is an agenda towards the a
great reset i mean klaus schwab wrote a
book about it to what extent does the
dude actually have the ability and the
power to implement something like that
speaking of resets you're from illinois
right yes
illinois new
safety act yeah okay funny name where
where you can't even protect your own
property you know trespassers can come
in and camp on your property on your
front porch and the police will not do
anything yeah
i mean what is going on they're
attacking property rights values across
the board in illinois you will own
nothing and you will be happy see this
is this is a good point the safety act
do you hear about this
they're saying
as you said the police won't respond to
trespassers on your property and they're
going to eliminate cash bail for most
criminal offenders murder
even murder okay but you guys realize
you're talking to a guy who's from
california
you're like hold my beer
chicago
you want me to it's already happened
here huh i mean i can go on and on
you're you're like oh the good old days
don't let them do it to you but this is
another example you're talking this is
chicago in the suburbs
dictating to the rest of the state yeah
well look i i mean we have
i always tell the story about
people who haven't been to california
recently you see the pictures of the
homeless that you see the pictures of
the nuttiness in san francisco and you
see the pictures in la and all the all
the popular places but those places have
always had homeless people it's just
that they've
they're 10 or 15x
where you didn't have homeless people
were in the rest of the state or if you
did they were kind of your traditional
hobo and you know you have onesies two
z's five maybe well let's let's let's
real quick let's uh let's break this
down hobo means homeward bound and it's
a reference to people moving right so
they might be sleeping outside but
they're leaving
vagrants i think are just you know
derelict individuals who mill about
vagabonds are see are travelers and then
a bum i think is somebody who doesn't
work
so
you know you get we got to make sure we
yeah those terms right right and that
but that's traditionally what you had
hobos but you just had a few a few of
each one of that category you just said
you know like in my home city you know
65 000 people
and you know you just have a handful of
people you'd please go out there work
with them and churches would take care
of them
and so i always tell people this it was
it was not that long ago it was
i think it was 2015.
i have a church across the street from
my house
and
there were two homeless people that
started living out there
and but that was it there was no in the
whole city that was the only ones i mean
there were a handful of others that
people were in and out of homes there
was places that they could get to
and i remember all my neighbors saying
oh my god can you these people are
living right there across the street
and they were that people were shocked
and they went to the church said look
you can't have these people living
across the street the church says well
look we're a home for you know we're a
church so we gotta you know help these
people
well then the two turned into six and
the six turned into twelve and then the
church said no solicitation put you know
so homeless people were gone from the
church
and then but they didn't go very far
and now in in my in my home city 65 000
people what started with just a handful
of homeless
okay
we now have estimated somewhere between
five and seven hundred
in my home city
but that's in every single city across
california so i call it it's like zombie
apocalypse we are welcoming all these
people here they have their own
governments
and so it's like stockholm syndrome
right i
remember how i just gave the story 2015
everybody's oh my god there's two
homeless people across the street
to now
there's zombies everywhere and nobody
does anything
i mean i've got literally
a football field away from me
and where i live
we've got a whole homeless encampment i
mean i can't my kids my girls can't walk
over to the little the little market
mini market because they gotta go
through a homeless camp so i i made this
point i think it was memorial day we
went to the movies and there was not a
soul in sight the movie theater was
empty the arcade machines had been
removed from it this is a big shopping
center in frederick and i'm walking
around and i'm looking around i'm like
where where are the people
no nobody's here nobody's out there's a
pool hall it's empty where'd everybody
go there's an ice cream shop
closed and it said we're closed due to
short staff and i was like where are the
people i recently went to um
what city is i can't remember the name
of the city i know it's in west virginia
and there's a diner at noon on a weekend
saying closed martinsburg martinsburg
that's the one closed due to short staff
and then i was just like where is
everyone and then ian made a good point
he goes a lot of more homeless people
popping up and i was like man is that
what's happening people aren't working
anywhere they're losing their homes they
can't afford it anymore and that's why
the homeless population is increasing so
much
i think what what at least what you see
in california and we're getting them
from all over the country
and it's really sad because
a lot of them are a product of of
of meth
methamphetamines oh man i started
watching breaking bad
their minds are all about it now
yeah
yeah
it's pretty bad i mean they're
you feel bad because there's not really
nothing
these people are never going to be able
to function in life and they just kind
of fall like i i hate calling zombies
but i don't really know what else to
call them they just kind of follow and
they have leaders methods and um yeah
but a lot of them aren't even doing meth
anymore i don't think crackheads yeah
they're just gone hunter vitamins well
heroin fentanyl whatever it is yeah you
know we got a big problem across the
whole country with this well it's a
plague well if you look at homelessness
a lot of it is usually correlated to it
not just drug addiction but a mental
health crisis and i think that mental
health crisis is getting worse and worse
especially by the numbers when you look
at depression self-harm suicide those
numbers have been going up dramatically
how do you how do you deal with this
type of situation and you know who do we
blame do we blame big pharma for the
opioid epidemic do we blame china for
the fentanyl that makes it worse do we
blame the fast food industry that's
creating an uh
a poor mental health do we blame social
media that's also creating poor mental
health do you
blame legalization of marijuana across
the whole country do you blame
you know i mean it could go on down the
list but the drug use across the board
contributes significantly to the mental
health issues because it does
create damage to the brain and the
functioning of a good segment of that
population alcohol though
yeah and alcohol i think substantially
worse than pot yeah but prohibition
didn't work you know and we were like
let's repeal that amendment that didn't
make sense it's funny that we i'm
surprised you know learning about
american history that they actually were
actually able to get a constitutional
amendment
just to get rid of alcohol yeah
i think it's crazy that you know
marijuana is still illegal in some
states but but doctors could prescribe
legalized heroin and get people addicted
and hooked on for the rest of their
lives that's a problem right there that
deserves to be called out and yes
marijuana is being genetically
engineered there's a whole bunch of
frankenstein marijuana that's really bad
especially for children but we can't
start with prohibition it never worked
it never has worked but but there is
something to say about how society has
failed most people and most people are
now becoming homeless or poor
more than ever yeah i think what you say
i mean all of these issues that we're
talking about there's there all of them
to some degree
matter
but but the challenge that we have in
california
is that you know
i always tell people stop if you don't
want bears stop feeding the bears
right i mean you you have to you have to
admit you have a problem and stop and
and we're getting more and more and more
of them and there's so many things that
have to be done to handle the problem
but it is i mean look nobody every time
i get on a plane i just when i when i
left california the other day
before i got stuck in in dallas and then
teleported to the secret meeting with
with president trump at the golf course
before all that it could have been your
evil twin though
could have been or good twin are you the
evil one but continue
but every time i fly i get oh i used to
hey you used to be my congressman back
in the day but you know i left to texas
like five years ago or three years ago i
mean every time it's people that are
still have business in california or
whatever but they've
moved their headquarters to a different
state wow
well the exodus is happening in illinois
too
maybe it's a self-correcting problem you
let them run amok and go crazy for long
enough and people are going to be like
i'm out how long before illinois goes
bankrupt i don't know how long i mean
can the state go bankrupt
well the biden will give him money he'll
find a way
they'll find a way to just pump money
into the system and keep keep the zombie
state hopping along well remember the so
in california you know we're going to be
all green right yet we're we're not
building any new ways to produce power
in mass in fact we shut down a nuclear
power plant we were talking about
nuclear a few minutes ago and then they
were going to shut down our last two
reactors that are still supplying 10 of
our power so i don't know if everybody's
paying attention but you couldn't charge
your car the other night
if you were in california you had to and
the governor sent a message to
everybody's phone saying turn off your
power now do you see the colorado when
the thermostats couldn't be changed
oh no i didn't energy crisis your
thermostat stuck at 78. well that that's
if you sign up for that program right
but people this is the thing they come
to you and they say do you want to sign
up for our smart saver program it's 100
bucks off your bill per year
sure sounds good all right have a nice
day and then all of a sudden you can't
change your thermostat it's not like
people knew they were signing up for
that yeah
but now they but they until they feel
pain so now newsome wants to run for
president he feels pain
there's we're on the verge of blackouts
all the time
and it's not just because of you
everybody says oh my god it's global
warming it's like no you idiots it
always gets hot in california during the
summer i mean it's not unusual for there
to be you know big spikes in in in it
doesn't happen in florida you know you
know what it is you're right it doesn't
i was in california during the drought
in like 2015
and ain't nobody stopped showering they
were like everybody got to limit your
water use and i knew people who were
like yeah but not me
and that was the mentality of almost
every single person they're all running
their long hot showers being like i
don't care yeah but the drought is so if
so do you now you're getting into my
wheelhouse now it's how i actually got
in politics was because this crazy water
issue so you realize that
like l.a san francis san francisco
is actually a desert nobody thinks of it
as a desert san francisco san francisco
is a desert but what the delta water is
what keeps it alive no what keeps it
alive actually was the
the founding fathers of the city
realized they needed some really fresh
good clean water
they went into yosemite national park
dammed up a valley not as big as
yosemite valley but one that was a small
mirror image of it just over the
mountain range they dammed it up it's a
dam called hedchechi
they dammed it up they piped the water
sorry how do you spell that hetch hetchy
h-e-t-c-h
easy enough yep
yeah oh hi yeah let's pull up the map
yeah so if you if you keep that map up
so back in the turn around the turn of
the century i'm talking about 1900 now
the
city of san francisco figured out hell
we don't have any water here we got to
do something because you can't drink the
salt water in the bay right yeah so they
they built that dam created that lake
and they pipe the water all the way over
to san francisco
all right that's where san francisco
gets its water wow now as the rest of
the state developed
all these water projects were built
and there's actually plenty of water in
the state you just have to move it
around you have to keep it in the wet
years
and you have to move it around because
it's not uncommon for california to go
through everybody says like you said
there was a drought in 15. yeah we have
droughts like all the time like you
you have a laser desert yeah you'll have
you'll have two wet wet years you'll
have four dry years you have one wet
year but but my point to say all this is
that
is it this is a man
made created crisis
like the people of california knew
that like when we had people with brains
they knew hey we better build some
nuclear power plants if we're going to
have 40 million people living here we
better build nuclear power plants clean
easy they work
and in fact the last what i was saying
about payne newsome now after
republicans the few republicans that are
left including our delegation said idiot
you're going to run the state of out of
power he finally acquiesced and said i'm
going to come in and save the nuclear
power plant not talking about how he was
the one that was going to shut it down
in the first place and the same thing is
water until people run out of water into
what you said tim that like they
actually don't have any water coming out
of the tap i've seen it there won't be
there won't be any pain nobody will pay
the price and they won't change their
methods of operation they just leave
well the conservative people leave well
everybody does even the liberal people
the liberal people vote for policies and
vote for people like newsome burn to the
ground and then go this sucks i'm
leaving i'm going to montana i'm going
to utah then they bring their policies
with them yeah and then it happens all
over again
it it's it's a cultural problem a lot of
this everything i think we're facing is
all cultural issues there are there
there is a sect of people right now and
it's mostly the the democrats the biden
supporters
they only care about saying what is
socially acceptable so of course they
repeat what they see on tv they believe
every single hoax and they vote for
policies that destroy everything so long
as the mob
they agree with the mob
they're content to just watch everything
burn these people
you know i feel like they've always been
here they've always been around but with
social media they've been trapped being
the spiral where they're all just
chasing each other it's a mexican
standoff of canceled culture
so you have people who are brave enough
to be like
i don't agree with that i'm not going to
agree with that and then they get mad at
you saying you're not agreeing with the
consensus reality so you're a bad guy
you're an extremist exactly that's the
white house you're an extremist so what
ends up happening is they say the
acceptable thing is that nuclear power
is bad the acceptable thing is that coal
power plants are bad then you end up
with no power doesn't matter they said
right thing good thing was said
therefore we good then the grid
collapses everyone suffers and they flee
to your state and they say the same
exact things
one by one just gutting and destroying
that's what i'm worried about with texas
look um mad respect to joe rogan you
know he recently said vote republican
did you guys hear this when they were
like what do you tell these people whose
businesses were shut down and he's like
what republican and they laugh
and people point out it's good that joe
moved to texas you know because he
opposes that stuff but what people don't
understand is that joe is surrounded by
wealth and industry and the people who
will follow him for him and not for
politics for political reasons are going
to bring liberal policies elon musk
brings the gigafactory to i think to
austin and everyone's like oh that's
great elon musk he's fleeing california
whoo and it's like and all of the people
who lived in california working for him
two to one it's democrats it's liberal
voters coming to texas now i think there
still is good news because it seems like
more anti-woke
anti-cult people are moving to texas and
it's going to help keep the state
red and you have the rio grande valley
which is uh has turned red so i think
it'll be okay well that will actually
dilute the cults that was one of the
things i was going to the
i think the the mexican vote in this
country and i specifically say you could
actually use the kind of the larger term
hispanic
but it's really the mexican boat that's
in texas in california arizona those
places if that vote actually begins to
shift and it doesn't have to shift very
much and if you if you remember in 2016
when trump won remember the fake news
had created this whole narrative that
trump was going to you know get rid of
all the hispanics they were all going to
be kicked out of the country remember
that yeah he posted that taco bowl
picture you know i didn't believe it for
a second well
but a lot of people did i mean it was it
was kind of a hard time because i felt
bad like like small kids that my wife's
a schoolteacher and i remember hearing
the stories about little kids actually
thought that they were gonna you know
that trump was like gonna come and you
know get them and and send them back
even though they were born in the united
states but that's the kind of damage you
talk about that this can do to to young
people and they these images but do you
know that in in the only growth area
that i saw
in the electorate in california in 18
and in 20 was with mexican-american
voters if you were working
mexican-american those those people and
actually working any anyone they're
moving republicans they're they're
they're shifting not quickly but they're
shifting we saw it on the rio grande
valley where you're not shifting uh
anybody who's college educated doesn't
matter what color what letter you use
you know as your pronouns you are going
to be you're shifting left well one of
the things on the exodus
the governor of new york says hey
republicans leave new york get out of
here we don't want you here yeah that
was amazing
in florida
there's now an 800 000 republican voter
advantage and it used to be the other
way around yeah
well us and rumble we're in sarasota
florida the new free speech capital true
socials in florida sarasota so is rumble
tim cass should move down to sarasota
florida that's what i've been telling
tim i visited sarasota i visited the
headquarters in rumble at rumble i was
like this is a great place tim got all
right all right yeah you guys should
move there well we'll need a that'd be
fun and i could come on the show all the
time we would need uh if the city can
provide some kind of like grant so that
we can relocate 30 plus employees and
build new infrastructure we otherwise
and tax incentives we'll just talk to
you know
ron and be like hey ron hook it up
just handed it the weather man this is
the problem it's not that bad
i lived in the redlands no income tax
yeah you lived in no individual income
tax yes you live deep inside of the
thing you got to be by the beach where
the breeze is it's cool it's fun it's
it's right it's 100 degrees with maximum
humidity
all the time no
miami air conditioning
sarasota's beautiful i loved it there i
thought the same thing so you know when
i was in dc like california gets hot
where i'm from i'm from the big
agricultural valley and i mean we'll get
105 you know we got 111 the other day
and
but i've never been hotter outside of
when i was in iraq a few times which
colonel harvey lived there for five or
six years so he can at least he could
tell you about real hot
but
but in dc i mean if it would be
in the 90s 95 with that nasty humidity
with no breeze
and like that's what you'll see
sometimes in miami but you're exactly
right i just think i've been shocked at
how even when i i thought oh man i'm
gonna the humidity is gonna suck in in
sarasota but there's always like this
breeze that comes off the gulf yeah it's
amazing i'm a big fan we shouldn't be
talking about sarasota because all your
we're going to have too many people too
many people are going to move and
they're already moving in i talked to
some locals that live there they're like
everyone's moving in everyone's taking
all the properties all the damn yuppies
are coming in here hey i'll tell you
what we'll build you a studio in our
office okay every state the average high
in january is 72.
perfect the average high in april mays
82 then 87 90 in june 91 in july 91 in
august 90 in september 86 in august
that's not that's not that different
than here that's very different from
here the average high in january here is
like 35.
i i still i'm a big florida man i love
florida i'm very biased in my uh you
know love affair why don't you
politically i like florida why don't you
do i'm just well it's just throwing
stuff at the wall i'm just this is just
this is it's a battleground it's a
purple state it's going to go either way
we need all the resources down in
florida we should build a winter cast
castle exactly just in october uh so in
and was it oh i don't even have december
pulled up i can teleport but you can
mind read yeah that's exactly what i was
saying november to february is what
we're based in florida and then we come
back
exactly and then you detoxify
all the toxins from your body and i i
sweat every single day skating luke
we're skating out there today all right
and we're and i'm covered in sweat and
luke's sitting there hunched over eating
a stromboli with pepperoni i was doing
pull-ups right before that all right i
did i did a little workout today so i
really came out with a balance board and
then he pulled out a stromboli and just
slouched it down it was like and i was
working out in the gym you can check the
surveillance cameras anyway uh not going
too personal because we got to do super
chats really yeah and and i really i was
three minutes away from this and i
wanted to ask you so many questions i
have i have like a list of questions i
really wanted to ask you uh but you got
to go to sarasota and then we'll and
we'll just we'll just do it from right
here right now um i really want to talk
about the intelligence committee because
i hear so many rumors just about being a
part of this this kind of uh committee
i'm hearing about people being scared of
losing their clearances i i heard even
dianne feinstein in 2014 talked about
how the cia was spying on this committee
how was it you know being a part of this
committee what was going on can you tell
us your experiences were you being spied
on was there's
what was going what was going on on the
inside you know at i actually had the
i'm probably the only person
or very few people on the planet who can
actually say this i went from the very
best job in the world
and within a matter of just a few months
to the very worst job in the world
okay so
i was i was having
uh you know it was it was tough work but
it was it was rewarding work you get to
work with patriots like colonel harvey
um a lot of the folks i worked with it
was very bipartisan you never heard from
the house intelligence committee
until
it was a sen until you got to the point
of you know if there was a terrorist
attack or some international issue
because
you know people didn't even really want
to serve on the intelligence committee
because it was hard work you had to do a
lot if you actually took it seriously
you had to do a lot of travel it wasn't
to great places you know except when
harvey and i were in
vienna that one time yeah yeah but
so
but then overnight trump wins
and then they turn it into
that you know everybody's a russian
agent everybody's rushing disinformation
so it went from the best job to the to
the worst job i mean i went under you
know because i had to sit there and take
all their [ __ ] for year after year i
mean look i'm still crazy i'm not even
congress in congress anymore and i mean
look they're still attacking you know my
former staff i mean cash patel i mean
they put him in a damn warrant the other
day with this you know that story that
we were talking about
was he said
the breitbart story that he was in so
well yeah i mean there's still i mean
every day this this it's like this they
put you in a story about a secret
meeting with donald trump on a golf
course yeah was there was there any more
retribution that you faced for speaking
out against what you knew was wrong and
what you were
right all along about
i mean look there's still
you have i mean like this is this is i
was getting you know
why did i leave why did i leave congress
it's because the flow the free flow of
information the internet is shut down
we're trying to create a beachhead
to open it back up
i mean it's that same and the way that i
realized it is is after the 2020
election
i thought to myself you know after you
know parlor got cancelled all that we
talked about earlier but another
important point is how could it be that
you still had over half of america at
that point according to polls that i'd
seen right after the election that
believed that trump and republicans
had something to do with russia they
don't know what
but they had somebody with russia and
that's when i said
oh my god like how did this happen like
i spent four years debunking this whole
damn thing it's a total hoax
and you still had half of america who
didn't know about it and who believe and
the counterbain story was censored and
the hundred biden story was censored
yeah yeah
is there anything that you were you were
you know a part of the committee that
that you were able to preview uh get
information about that you knew as
everyone else was wrong about other than
just the the whole russian gate
well other than harvard i know china we
were doing a lot on china
identifying
what china was doing in technology
espionage pushing that china was a real
threat and that was that was before
trump
yeah we ran along i mean actually our
china investigation dated back um
dated back a long time and we were you
know
and colonel harvey was running that
investigation for us
there's a lot there i mean china's a big
problem
but
you know we wouldn't be happy warriors
for the rest of night not get depressed
what did ronald reagan say if you want
to be if you want to be depressed go
outside and lie down
let's uh let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button give a little tap
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com head over there click the
join us button because we're going to
have a members only uncensored show
coming up at 11 p.m tonight you don't
want to miss it but let's read what
y'all have to say
all right
leore engelstein says i'll start off the
super chats by saying a government that
has created enough laws that the average
citizen breaks 20 federal laws a day is
the same as quote show me the man and i
will tell you the crime yes you see that
viral video of the cop where she's like
if you're in front of me get out of my
way if you don't get out of my way i'm
behind you long enough i can find a
reason to get you it's like oh yeah show
me the men i'll show you the crime that
was a strong bureaucratic becky there
well that's what we used to say about
mueller the molar the molar witch hunt
was an investigation in search of a
crime
yeah
jason d says tim you mentioned a while
back that michael graves might come on
the show any plans for that would be
great to hear what he's got to say these
days oh yeah we'll reach out to him it's
been a while yeah he's cool
we'll uh we'll talk to the crew and see
what uh
what we got dano says i am a sub at tim
cast and i can't give much but after the
video about schools today i wanted to
support you more to hopefully support
that micro school more that you gave to
thanks tim for all you do so yeah
there's a micro school out here you guys
familiar with the concept
basically what you do is you got a bunch
of kids who are homeschooled and you put
them in the same place
they're sc the school is based on
instead of a grade classroom students
have grades so if a student has a sixth
grade reading level but an eighth grade
math level then
that's what they have and then as soon
as they finish the tests they level up
that way the kids can move as quickly or
as slowly as they need to but it's
basically
get your kids out of the public school
system it's super corrupt homeschool
your kids and this is the step up from
homeschooling it's basically well it's
the step up from pods do you know about
pod learning all the all the families
get their kids together they hire a
tutor you do that with like
you know 10 times as many kids and now
you've got a micro school so i recently
made a contribution in the low five
figures to help a micro school get
started out here make sure they have
books and the kids can get good learning
and uh there's some religious values
involved and i think it's a good idea
especially considering how they're
trying to indoctrinate kids at schools i
thought it was a it's important thing to
do so i dana uh dana i really appreciate
the support this was my personal you
know contribution
just wanted to help these uh
these schools and put my money where my
mouth is
adam noel says ian mentioned jackson
mississippi last night i just want to
point out their mayor
chokwe antar lumumba is a
self-proclaimed progressive and
socialist coincidence i don't think so
don't know does that have anything to do
with them not having water
no idea no no no sorry
raymond g stanley jr says tim talking to
my normie bro about the midterms his
exact words were wait it's only the
midterms biden has two years left it got
this bad that fast
yes man hate to say i told you so
john kirsten says last two days no
notification on when live started but
got one monday wtf youtube many such
cases what are you gonna do
i think sorry guys i think youtube would
love to end this show
algorithmically they can't just delete
it i mean it technically could but it
would create a big splash and they try
to avoid that so what they do is
removing notifications makes it so
slightly less and less people will find
the show the only problem for youtube is
that we have strong draw and people
choose to come and watch the show so
thank you all who do and y'all share the
show so when a notification doesn't go
out here's the good news y'all can be
the notification so if youtube wants to
put the uh
jamma if they want to jam us up not put
out notifications even for those who
selected it all you have to do is take
the url of this video and post it on any
social media you can and that will be 10
times more powerful than any
notification wait you guys get
notifications here yeah luke's been
looking i haven't had that for years
luke fredsel says chris cheated ian
needs justice free the september 6th
prisoners cass castle union is crooked
if you guys haven't been watching cass
castle there's a funny story arc going
on
where ian runs for union president but a
bunch of uh early ballots come in at 3
a.m and chris ends up winning and so uh
yeah
brother brovet says youtube didn't send
notices link to the show is bad
well there you go y'all still found the
show somehow so thanks for for tuning in
mount jeeves says they get away with it
because the people they look to tell
them to vote and wait to be saved
instead of organizing
well i gotta i gotta uh halt a little
bit of that comment because we are uh
first of all
it's a little too spicy
and we are we are two less than two
months away from an election where we
actually have prominent maga republicans
america first republicans who are set to
win
we've got you know people like corey
mills in florida we've got people like
carrie lake the governor of arizona you
are so close to tasting a real victory
you should get your friends to go vote
seriously
eric miller says tim i'm hearing due to
supply constraints that congress could
deny the railway rights to strike could
be why jb and the dams aren't worried
yeah what do you guys think about that
with the railway track could they stop
the strike from happening
the president has the authority i think
they would have it can delay for a while
i'm not sure how long it is
like what if you know is what i was i
never understood i was told it was like
illegal for firefighters or cops to
strike and i'm like oh yeah you could
just not show up like what are they
going to do if you're like then i'm out
i quit this is what this is why i don't
like unions that's why i despise unions
you got a company right that says a
thousand people and the the what's
happening with the company it's it's
really really bad the wages are really
bad they're not able to feed their
families and they say you know what i've
had enough who's with me
well collective bargaining is awesome
all of these people can then just be
like then we're out we are not going to
work and we agree but now with these
union laws they're like we can legally
stop you from striking and i'm like well
no one's stopping you from quitting so
the collective bargaining is still there
i think the problem with unions is that
they actually hinder people's ability to
organize properly people should organize
more
i think the biden administration is the
administration of chaos and i think um
it's not something that they want to
prevent i think it's something that they
want to spur on because it's going to
work in their benefit when it comes to
the larger destruction of our economy
that they have been already engineering
but that's just my opinion if they if
they strike i mean just
let's take my part of california
you know you have to remember we're an
agricultural area we have living animals
right that rely on
grain
imported i mean one of the reasons why
the united states is such a such a
strong country is because we can feed
ourselves we have more food here than
than we can consume
but if the food can't move around the
country especially when you have living
animals that rely on that grain from the
midwest you know you could be facing
that's just one little example of i mean
like you don't have
like if the trains don't run for three
or four days
within a week we have starving animals
in california you don't have the
commodities going to the kellogg's
factories or purina or others that gets
processed into real food remember how
crazy they went about the baby food
crisis you know the baby formula crisis
i mean you could have that on a large
scale i mean there there is no way they
can let these treasures and then travel
and fuel oil
we're going to go back to wood yes
well wood
is not a carbon emitter
when you burn it the epa says wood is
natural therefore we're not going to
regulate it what right it's not it's you
know i'm going to build a steam engine
i'm going to build a wood a wood powered
steam engine
generate electricity with uh wood you
know i i've been thinking about it
people tell me to get a diesel generator
and i'll like you get an engine that
spins okay why don't i just build my own
steam engine with a piston i'll just do
that
then i'll power my house with trees yeah
what are they gonna do about it or move
to florida
well we got solar too so
but florida sunny
rant milk says tim pool would you kindly
turn my tv off the next time you steal
my spoons
so um what is that so they're like you
know with shows like this come stalkers
and there there was one person it was
one of my favorite they claimed on
twitter that i showed up to their house
at 2am thousands of miles away from
where the studio is
and walked in their house and turned
their tvs on and it woke up their family
and they were really pissed off that it
happened
and people believed it
they they actually like wow i can't i
can believe he would do that haha so
crazy and i'm like bro i don't i'm
thousands of miles away from this place
why would you believe that i did that
because people are insane they want to
believe
they do
augusto mimoshe says as a libertarian
and ron paul supporter i demand an
apology and i told you and i told you so
rights from conservatives for the
patriot act etc
that's correct a lot of ron paul
libertarians were warning uh republicans
that the powers that they have given
themselves after 9 11 will eventually be
used against them and i think that's
yeah well i i mentioned that i think you
know we were talking about the creation
of the dni the one thing that you have
to that you do have to remember
about the patriot act
if you look at all the crimes that have
been committed recently it actually it's
even worse than the patriarch you have
to actually go back 30 years
in the creation of the fisa court which
had nothing to do that so it's not even
the patriot it's it's going all the way
back to what was done after the church
commission in the 1970s and 80s so and
rand paul and i have talked about this
you know
at nauseam that was a very important
commission that revealed a lot yeah and
laws were put in and now those laws are
being broke
from that time it's not just the ones
that were put in after 9 11. you have to
go all the way back to i don't know i
forget i think it's 78 i think i was
just thinking of something you know i
totally i'm going to derail totally but
um one of the segments we've done we did
for two days ago it's called tic toc is
making young girls completely insane and
it's getting hundreds of thousands of
hits it's like going viral on youtube
and i'm like why that one why why is our
segment about tick tock making young
girls insane just getting like hundreds
of thousands of hits and you know even
right now and then i went oh i wonder if
china spying on americans yeah okay
we're in agreement there youtube prop up
my videos well
their algorithm is totally different for
american children than it is for chinese
children and you could see the
degradation of our society that's being
influenced by these social media
programs and it's in it's wild it's more
more promoting tim cast segments and
ragging on tick tock how about that
all right perfect i'm going to make a
trick type video tomorrow social too
social of course ginger mick isaac says
devon i voted for you also started save
the endangered california farmer you
were one of my first members thanks for
all you did for the beleaguered farmers
by the way taxifornia refugee now
another one another another person fled
yep yep
it's a bummer thank you by the way
tom bear says senate intel on both sides
helped spread this hoax dick burr a
drunk hack lady g etc
dura uh durham has always been a cleaner
for the regime see what he did in the
bulger intrigues in the ca black sites
facts
i don't know
maybe
we'll see we'll see what durham comes up
with here we're getting ready we're
getting ready for a trial
of uh who's who's facing trail right now
who's uh dan chenko and durham's going
to be the prosecutor
the russia he's the guy who was the
secret russian source it was actually a
democrat operative in a confidential
human source and that's yeah that was
the joke we started out with he's the
guy who's now the confidential human
source that they had from us and stephen
halper was a confidential human source
aaron elizabeth says it's a wish order
we ordered trump but got devin jk love
you man connecticut is going red
don't count us out we are pissed yeah so
the other night we were like we're gonna
have a big show tomorrow and then i
guess because trump was in dc everybody
was like trump come on you know and then
when when devin shows up they're like oh
oh yeah but now i'm gonna be really
disappointed now that the tick tockers
are gonna do better than uh than colonel
harvey and i
yeah but if it was any other day you
know
robert muir says we're
stop letting others define whom you are
to you people will say whatever they
want about you something you can really
you can really do about it
that is what it is
but to yourself you can always know who
you are
richard lease says ask devin if he
thinks obama is pulling all the strings
with these scandals
yes
interesting oh that was easy yeah i know
i mean
if you look at who's running the white
house right now susan rice yeah it's
susan rice and and um
uh
monaco was uh was involved in the russia
hoax and you have a jake sullivan they
were all involved in the russia hoax
they've all been promoted aren't they
bringing podesta back too and then
podesta's coming back too yeah wow
yeah they just recycle through i mean
it's all the same people and speaking of
recycling
you look at the number of senior fbi and
senior democratic doj officials
like baker who go to facebook or go to
twitter or go to these other social
media companies
as senior senior people at those and
then they spend some time there and they
go back and they go back into dni or
someplace like that there's this
relationship and we can't seem to get
into it obama even said that he would
love to come back as president but not
be president but be the person calling
all the shots behind the scenes a couple
years ago so he's been making statements
about this possible reality
chris povoto says for anyone else door
knocking or with colleagues talking with
cox about voting when the economy and
inflation comes up ask isn't it crazy
why those in control at dc haven't
pushed for a federal minimum wage
increase
i think it's a good point you know the
argument you have a lot of democrats
talking about all these problems but
they're not actually pursuing what many
of the democratic voters are asking for
not that i think it'll solve the problem
i had a voter the other day make the
point that the democrats in washington
dc are doing to their constituents their
policies are undermining and attacking
minorities
immigrants of all types
okay
lower income people because of inflation
and their tax structures the irs it's
going to go after all of them
it's not going to their policies are
going after who they claim to be their
base
i mean look dc has changed over the you
know when i first went there
i mean it used to be you know a city
where
you know you had a large uh
african-american population and largely
that population has been pushed out been
pushed out into maryland and and dc's
like this new
like i mean it's i i don't know if it's
got it's got to have one of the highest
per capita incomes in the country i mean
there's a new apartment number there's
there's cranes everywhere the
construction's never stopped um and
essentially they the city has become a
place for young
one percenter liberals
yeah
all rights
benjamin dover
interesting name there ben
mr dover first name ben
railroad is going to strike and things
will get much much worse food energy and
fuel prices to the moon
part of me thinks that they will not be
able to stop this strike and part of me
thinks they want the strike to happen
just with how bad everything's gotten
and this idea of the great reset you
will own nothing and you'll be happy
artificial scarcity
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if they're
like oh no a rail strike and now there's
no food anymore whoops
well it's
they what could they come up with
because it's a crisis and they'll take
advantage of any crisis to push through
new programs and new authorities
yeah well they're telling farmers in the
netherlands to stop farming while
they're also saying there's going to be
a major food shortage because of ukraine
so something doesn't add up
just the way it is fire of destruction
says tim i listen while i drive at work
that said i love the guests you have on
i'll also listen to the quartering and
he said he's trying to pass you in subs
in today's episodes in today's episode
well you know good for him
i uh
i don't know what to say what to say
about i don't really pay attention any
of that stuff
i remember uh
you know when we started tim cast irl i
had two other channels that were you
know had large followings
and if if the whole mentality of
starting a channel was we have to get
more subject to get bigger i think you
would lose what makes a channel actually
work we did the show because we had fun
doing it and we just keep doing it and
uh subscribe subscriber uh growth slowed
down in an off-season year during in 20
in in in primary years presidential
primaries and presidential elections and
subscriber growth is just bonkers
because everybody's now wrapped up in
politics you know so it's gonna get it's
gonna get crazy for everybody in
politics in this in this coming year and
then uh 2024 is
2024 is going to be insane 2023 building
up to it is going to be oh i know it's
going to be nuts i mean the fact that
they're already gearing up for the
presidential cycle in 2022 is just like
yeah and numbers don't matter anymore
your subscribers don't matter it's the
algorithm that matters and a lot of
people go crazy on youtube just chasing
these numbers and it's not a healthy
lifestyle
yeah how many subs does uh does jeremy
even have anyway
no idea he's got let's see he's got
1.29 million subs oh you know really
close yeah cool
we like jeremy he's cool dude he uh he
gave us a lot of money when we got when
we got swatted he was well selling his
coffee it was like 500 bucks i think he
gave us more than that didn't he i don't
know use multiple channels or something
yeah
all right all right let's grab some more
let's grab some more of uh
musically assured destruction says will
putin try to force ukraine to be neutral
this way nobody has it
i mean i guess a wasteland is neutral
right
yeah i don't i mean
neutrality isn't what he wants
all right iggy the incubus says question
for devon what was the biggest high and
low of your time in government do you
believe that it can still be fixed if so
how
well a lot of good stories i think i
talked earlier about the you know when i
had the best job you know to the to the
worst job but in many ways
as bad as the job was at the there at
the end with the russia hoax i mean at
least
at least we were able to tell the
american people the truth and at least
that at least that's that's out there
probably uh you know one of my funniest
stories in in politics
was
i had a guy this was when i was first
elected
he called me called the office
and he said i have a
a bear in my backyard and he's eating
the fruit off my trees and i said well
there's not really much we can do about
it you got to call fish and game blah
blah let us help you and he said no no i
want you to come out and
and kill the bear
so finally he kept so i said finally i
told one of my my district director at
the time
i said would you just cause we thought
maybe the guy was just going a little
senile because he sounded like he was
really old
and and he was really old and went out
there his old world war ii that
and got it there the guy was kind of
lonely and i'll be damned if the bear
wasn't there
and so when we tried to work with the
all the fish and game commission all
these people to try to go kill the damn
bear
and or you know cap you know usually
they would capture it and take it off
and so the guy kept calling kept calling
kept calling finally we just said okay
screw it and a couple of guys that i
know said look we'll just go kill the
bear for the guy
and so they went out there to kill the
bear
and uh
and the guy says you know i just like
you guys coming out here and i really
don't have any friends my wife died and
please don't shoot the bear but will you
guys keep coming out and just hang out
with me
wow it was a cool story
all right here's one liquid logic says
can devin nunes provide insight into why
assange was not pardoned by trump and
will trump make a commitment to pardon
assange if he runs in 2024 trump would
win in a landslide by winning
independents and moderates
oh that's a you know the assad situation
is one that there's just not a lot of
information on i know people are very
passionate about it that you know on the
kind of that front
but um you know we just don't there's so
much that is unknown about it about
assaj that
you know because we you know many people
i mean i think even um
i think even sean hannity went over
there
um you know and tried to get him you
know several you know several prominent
people have tried to get asajj to like
hey kind of like hey this is your chance
give us everything you have and he's
never truly came forward with everything
that he has i would run his credibility
yeah no i i i realized but he couldn't
do it but he's in it but it's it's kind
of a
catch-22 situation because if he doesn't
do it then
you know then people are going to say he
broke the law
i think it's all i think it's all bs i
think what you know they they go after
him like uh you know obama i think went
after more whistleblowers and journalism
under the espionage act than i think all
other presidents combined if that's the
case julian assange and wikileaks they
accepted leaks and they published them
but the new york times does the exact
same thing the issue is that wikileaks
was just very effective and it was out
of their reach
so
at the very least you could look at what
they did with julian assange in sweden
they first get them locked up under some
ridiculous claims about swedish you know
rape laws or something because a condom
broke which is ridiculous and then
ultimately drop those as soon as the u.s
intervenes and i think it was correct if
i'm wrong uh luke it was trump that
ordered the the the uh raid on the
ecuadorian embassy right
um it was under his administration i
believe uh we i gotta fact check that to
be completely honest my view is that i
think trump wanted to bring assange over
here because he knew assange had answers
about what was going on and could
provide
some evidence and testimonials won't do
it because wikipedia won't he wouldn't
give up his his credit there was
allegedly an offer from the trump
administration asking assange to reveal
his sources of the the leak and assange
said he wouldn't do that that's the
story allegedly that we heard from a
mutual friend of ours
yep i'm not sure trump was involved in
any of it
i'm not sure would get to hit his level
it was his it was under his
administration no i understand i mean
yeah he's publicly talked about
wikileaks
this is the conflicting part he said he
loved wikileaks he he loved what julian
assange did he promoted the leaks and he
came out there on the campaign and he
was like all for it and then when he was
asked about it later on uh during his
political cure he was like julian
assange who wikileaks who and he acted
like he didn't know who they were so
there's a big difference between his
later statements and his earlier
statements i don't know a whole lot
about the ross albrecht thing i think
you might know more than that yes
that's a big case as well but people are
saying he should be pardoned he should
have been pardoned
absolutely free ross.org i think has a
website detailing that particular
circumstance which also is egregious
from my point of view
i think trump should have pardoned all
non-violent drug offenders
like who didn't plead down so it's like
people who had you know varying degrees
of potty just smell like we're parting
all of it yes there's a lot of people
that definitely deserved pardons but uh
you know kodak black
like definitely makes you wonder what
was going on there yeah
what do you guys think about the bannon
stuff
you know the the accusations that he was
swindling money or whatever from trump
supporters
i mean look that was uh
it's the it's new york that's going
after him
blue state deep blue he was already
pardoned federally they didn't seem to
ever have a case against him and i think
he's being targeted i think you know i
mean look at how the look at how
you know you've got the same people that
are going after after trump you've got
the same people you know and they're
doing the same thing in georgia it's the
weaponization of the justice system
and i mean look if you're going to go
after
after people for uh look what bannon has
said publicly about this over and over
again he hasn't hid from it he's been
very from what i can tell very
transparent about what they were what
they were doing you know look it's not
something that
that i would do but it just seems like
he's a political target
by this standard you'd have to be
investigating charging and bringing the
prosecution thousands of these
non-profit people thousands
yeah
but the standard's not being applied
across the board
it's selective yep
dana ness says i will gladly pay you
tuesday for a hamburger today is from
popeye the character's name is wimpy in
the robin williams movie he even sings a
song about it oh who knows this stuff
oh the audience knows everything
they really do
wimpy
is that is there this is crowd sourcing
yeah that's right
man a lot of people pointing out that
they're not getting notifications
anymore and uh you know we're working on
a mobile app and so i'm just imagining
it's gonna be great y'all will download
the mobile app and then at like 7 55 a
little thing over and it'll be like
we're live in five minutes come hang up
that'll be super cool
long as you can get on the google play
store
yeah i think an apple app store
we'll see though
that that's crazy how they do that
though but we're still waiting we're on
the apple app store but we're not on the
google play store even though we have a
very family-friendly clean put on the
website you can you can put the apq on
your website
we actually have that or you can go do
it but you know like if you're under the
age of 40 45 people that have androids
know how to do that but you know if
you're like my dad's age you don't know
you you only know how to use the google
play store yeah
it's very complicated they're just it's
attrition making it hard enough to
hinder you is good enough you know right
wise guy as a dick says don't do a steam
engine do a wood powered gasifier you
can use hydrogen gas to power everything
really
well i don't i don't know how that would
work the only thing that i can think of
in my mind that i could probably build
from scratch is like a wood is a steam
engine because it's like a relatively
simple thing to build granted i'm not
talking about actually like making the
metals or anything but i could like buy
the parts and i have a general concept
of how to make a steam engine but i
don't know what a gasifier is i actually
watch the youtube video on how to make a
steam engine it's really cool they had a
glass one it's like a little little
bunsen burner and a little candle and
then it just makes a piston spin a wheel
good fun stuff steam engine stuff
you know we used to have thousands and
thousands of little little dams and all
these creeks and little rivers
you know wisconsin illinois
a lot of communities had them they
generated electricity just for their
small towns
they're all gone
but if we want to clean energy
yeah why don't we do that
the water just keeps flowing yep
and if you don't have the water you die
anyway so what will you care about
electricity you got to leave oh but
there's probably a minnow there we need
to protect
yeah that's what's happening right now
in the delta right the the fish
no that's the smelt
yes
look it up fact check me out oops i love
it delta smelt yes you're welcome oops
boops you are welcome
all right let's grab some more super
chats mission says i'm originally from
fresno california they love devin nunes
out there he will be missed thank you
sir
why do people call san garcia the
chancula
the chancella
always wondered chankla chankla is that
it is you can't see it it's the the
prince it's too small the flip-flop the
chocolate yeah
yeah well you know i don't know i mean
sanger's beautiful little city lots of
homeless there now too just like my home
city but not far from not far from where
i live
oh yeah i i want to mention real quick
too before we wrap up i think we're
going to do a car giveaway
we're going to be giving yeah we're
planning it and uh more information to
come soon it's going to be really fun
really fun yeah i was thinking about
doing an rv giveaway as well with your
rv luke yeah
it'll be good to upgrade what kind of
car electric uh uh 2004 chevy cobalt
with 216 000 miles on it okay okay yeah
so we have this like so here's what
happened hey someone could use it we're
at a party i don't think he can move but
we're at a car dealership and i was we
were getting a new work vehicle and then
someone traded it in and then we looked
at it and it was like like
you know and then
i think my brother was just like how
much do you want for that and it was
like a couple hundred bucks they were
like i guess like
trading it in but there's no real value
to it you can take it now and so now we
have this just ridiculous car for no
reason and then i was like we should we
should do a giveaway like a sweepstakes
and we'll make an ad for it because i
always see these ads on facebook where
it's like you could win a maserati and
so we're gonna do like you could win
this car and it's a got 216 000 miles on
it
hey man well actually colonel harvey's
got several of those he's like into
collecting cherokee jeeps yeah i have a
92 a 96 and a 98 jeep cherokee sports
and one's really nice i mean i got it
lifted up and
you know it's good for off-road
right on well ladies and gentlemen if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends head over to timcast.com become
a member we have that members only show
coming up for you about 11 p.m and also
if you are ever using spotify you can
add our songs will of the people and
only ever want it to your playlists
you can follow the show at tim castro
you can follow me at tim cast devon you
want to shout anything out hey just
thanks a lot it's been a real pleasure
to be out here and we're looking forward
to having you down in florida oh yeah
yeah thanks for coming man it's been fun
solar panels steam engines whatever you
need derek you've been on the show
several times but do you want to shout
anything out you're running for office
too i think right yeah i'm running for a
county commissioner in washington county
right here where we're at and if you
want to check me out or make a donation
online it's at
votederrickharvey.com that's d-e-r-e-k
h-a-r-v-e-y
awesome uh my youtube channel is we are
change and uh it's something really
weird and strange is going on there but
if you want to see my information
downloads with my co-host atlas you can
youtube.com forward slash we are change
hope to see you there thanks for having
me thank you guys very much for tuning
in this evening we very much appreciate
it as always even though you didn't get
the notification you guys can follow me
on twitter and mines.com at sarah
patrick's as well sarah patrick's dot me
we'll see all of you at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you